[Music]
oh i love this
[Music]
nba legend michael jordan is one of the
world's most iconic athletes and a
global marketing powerhouse now the man
who runs jordan's biggest brand is
revealing a dark secret he kept hitting
for decades even from the superstar
himself this morning nike jordan brand
chairman larry miller also the former
president of nba's portland trailblazers
is out with his new book jump my secret
journey from the streets to the board
room he's sharing a story with special
correspondent james brown in an
interview you're seeing first on cbs
mornings jb what's good to see all of
you guys and of course he knows gail
very well who doesn't she know right so
no question about it good morning to you
all and you're about to hear from a man
who rose to the pinnacle of one of
america's best-known brands working
right alongside as nate mentioned
michael jordan and find out what he was
hiding all the way to the top
i didn't have to do this right i i could
have just continued to keep doing what i
was doing and hope that it never came
out
larry miller led michael jordan's
best-known brand for us it was like okay
let's try and create a brand that is the
michael jordan of brands
that's him right behind jordan in 2005
on 60 minutes so it's not just
here's my name use it oh no no i i you
know
i do have a sense i like control
making it all the more shocking that
while the pair shared courtside seats
for decades miller didn't share his
darkest secret
it's like not just what happens on the
court how his own story started in a far
different court fortunate for me never
came out
arrested at age 12 and in a gang by 13
in 1965 at this west philadelphia
intersection miller's young life came to
a crossroads i had a gun and we just
decided we were going to go look for
somebody one of my gang members had been
killed i was angry drunk and
crazy mr white just happened to be at
the wrong place at the wrong time
miller just 16 at the time shot and
killed 18 year old david white
white left behind an eight-month-old son
and a daughter who wasn't born yet it
was totally senseless
there was nothing that he did to cause
this
did you ever even fathom that there was
a possibility that you could do
something like that no no i didn't there
was always this voice in the back of my
head saying you know you shouldn't be
doing this and the thing is i just
wouldn't listen to it
quickly arrested at this youth prison
miller earned his g.e.d i gave the
valedictorian speech at the high school
graduation inside the penitentiary i
remember my closing line it was
let's not serve time let's let time
serve us
miller served fewer than five years for
murder
by age 20 he was already out got out
knocked around got pulled back into
street stuff sent back to prison for a
series of stick-ups here miller again
saw education as the key to his release
you could actually
take college classes inside the jail it
was because of that program that i was
able to really change my life
the crazy thing is i've been out now for
40 years and there are still people
there that were there when i was there
which could have been you which could
have absolutely been me
instead miller earned an accounting
degree from temple university
then up for a significant corporate job
he made the faithful decision to divulge
his past he said and i had an offer here
already to give you but i can't give it
to you now and
at that point
i decided that i wasn't going to share
this anymore i wasn't going to lie and i
never i never did
millard landed jobs at campbell soup
jansen swimwear and then nike but in the
book he writes the secret malignant grip
on my life had grown more toxic
dark dreams fueled paranoia during the
day which made the next night's dreams
even darker nightmares migraines i there
were a couple times i ended up having to
go to the er because i was holding all
of this angst and fear
miller's oldest daughter and co-author
laila lacy here visiting him in prison
said it took over 12 years to convince
her father to come forward how do you
think your dad handled
the secret all this time
it's funny you know
until we started writing
i didn't know about the migraines i
didn't know about the nightmares i
didn't know how he was struggling
and lacey also struggled learning the
details of her father's crimes
i
saw them as a mother
of a black boy
and it was painful but
it
helped me to come into an understanding
of we all deserve
a second chance now there's no one that
i meet
ever that i think is unredeemable
and on his own path to redemption miller
knew whom to call i remember telling
michael and he said i agree with your
daughter you need to tell this story
tragic news for basketball superstar
michael jordan jordan whose own father
was murdered just weeks after he won his
third nba title
urged miller to contact the family of
david white
but a month after miller told sports
illustrated he planned to reach out
white's family spoke out to say they had
not heard from miller it was painful
it
still is painful this is sam the
daughter david white never met was upset
to learn his name never even appears in
miller's book i didn't like how that
made me feel
that he did not give my father a name
it was just as if he was some homeless
person
that hurt were you still trying to
shield a part of the story
was there any lack of
respect
for them as a family in hindsight i
should have reached out to them should
have tried to locate and find them much
sooner than we did last month
they finally match how did it go
went great
so when i listened to him he remorseful
he had uh his
his eyes watered up and i felt okay
to forgive him it happened he did it
not forgiven what compelled you
to speak the words
i forgive you someone asked jesus how
many times
must i
forgive as many times as necessary
and we all have sinned
so i have to i have to forgive him was
that a very tough process for you to go
through
i told mr miller
if i was 30 years younger
i'd jump across that table
and whip his behind
but now but now i'm good
basketball more than 40 years after
leaving prison
miller says he's also
finally free
how badly
did it eat at you the thought and the
idea that i took the life of a young
black man has eaten at me
for years and i'm hoping that maybe
you know there's a 16 year old larry
miller out there that's
about to do something crazy and by
sharing this maybe it'll
stop someone or make someone else
think twice about doing something that
they're going to regret later in life
larry miller certainly is walking the
road to redemption and he plans to
donate some of his books proceeds to the
philadelphia juvenile justice services
center and the vera institute of justice
paying it forward and he's also working
with the white family to set up
scholarships plural to benefit
descendants of david white and others in
the west philadelphia neighborhood where
they both grew up and let me just say
quickly while this story certainly is
about one of redemption for larry miller
it is absolutely about forgiveness on a
part of the family you know many people
characterize it you know
having anger against somebody who's done
something to you is taking the poison
yourself thinking it's going to kill the
other person ms mack
is the real
all it does is eat you up there's so
many different layers to this story i am
so glad that he reached out to the white
family and that they were able to have a
meeting and and then for larry to admit
that at 16 he killed them basically for
no reason yeah and when you think about
that when you're 16 years old and the
decisions that you've made and how that
must have eaten at him all these years
and he talked about it with his dreams
but i heard nate comment about getting
drunk as well with cheap wine none of it
excuses it but absolutely i didn't i
never knew the story i just got the book
yesterday i can't wait to read it i
never knew the story it just shows you
how everybody has a story
and you never know what's going on in
someone's life
and his story proves and i think this is
one of the best stories we've ever aired
it proves that the thing you do on the
worst day of your life is not all you
are yeah and a number of mates friends
are doing this with the uh the players
coalition and the nfl going around to
make significant changes specifically in
the justice system as you but tony to
your point larry miller did say that
people that are still in prison
from when he was there i think that's a
step absolutely and i'm glad that they
uh have created a scholarship or
scholarships in the name of david white
that was killed i mean you can't replace
a life no question you can't make the
relatives of
his family happy i love the forgiveness
from the yeah no doubt about it that is
the story it's clearly remorseful too
you feel great today
i'll see you sunday absolutely larry
miller's book jump is on sale today